[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, everybody.
Laurence Moroney from
The Developer Show.
I'm here at the TensorFlow
Developer Summit.
And it's my honor to
speak with Justine Tunney.
Justine, you're the Dev
Lead for TensorBoard.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: I am.
Thank you for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
you're very welcome.
And, Justine, you've
just done a great talk
on TensorBoard and on the plugin
ecosystem for TensorBoard.
It's a very vibrant ecosystem.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Oh, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Could
you tell us about it?
And the debugger in particular.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: We've had
many amazing plugins developed
for TensorBoard
over the past year.
And the featured plugin
was the debugger plugin,
which sort of gives you
an X-ray into your models,
in terms of black
box explainability.
TensorBoard originally
had, I guess
you could say,
features like scalers
that were the flashlight.
This is an X-ray,
because it actually
allows you to step
and set breakpoints
interactively in your model.
And you can literally
watch the tensors
as they flow in real time.
It's pretty incredible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
people will believe
we called it
TensorFlow for a reason
now, because you can
see them, like you say,
flowing in real time.
So, cool.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: And
speaking of tensors flowing,
like one of the illuminating
things about this debugger
plugin is that it operates
on the actual graph.
A lot of times when we
write code for TensorFlow
or our machine
learning models, we're
using really high-level
frameworks and libraries
like CARIS and Estimator.
And underneath those frameworks,
and the nice Python code,
are now Swift code.
There's the reality of the graph
through which the tensors flow,
and that's what this
debugger operates on.
It lets you see the reality
beneath the abstractions when
you need to, even though we
[INAUDIBLE] the abstractions.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's super cool.
But just the thought of
like, as a developer,
I load my data
into a model, train
my model, that kind
of thing, and then run
my model against test data.
And you have that
whole black box.
I couldn't really figure out
if I'd optimized my model,
but you're saying I can--
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Well,
speaking of optimizing models,
like one interesting
thing is there is now
a supervised training
plugin that was contributed
by Francois Luus at IBM.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah, OK.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: And this is
part of the embedded projector
[INAUDIBLE].
He sent us some poll
requests, because we
do our development in the open.
And what it allows you
to do is interactively
assign labels to your data set.
And you allow the
algorithms, such as t-SNE,
to sort of reveal the
structure of your data.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: And you edit
the labels as you go along.
It's pretty cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
was that called again?
JUSTINE TUNNEY: You
can search for, I
believe it was called supervised
training with TensorBoard.
There's an IBM blog
post that explains it.
It's part of TensorBoard's
embedding projector plugin.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we'll
put a link in the description
below for people
watching it on YouTube.
So you've mentioned
the debugging.
You've mentioned
this other plugin.
There's a massive, vibrant
ecosystem, right, of plugins.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Indeed there is.
And, in many ways, the role
of the TensorBoard team
and my latest
[INAUDIBLE] developer
is to provide a really
sturdy, solid foundation
for all these contributions
from many teams
and a few companies with
which we've been entrusted.
For example, we've got a
rock-solid build foundation,
where you can actually
build your code in China,
America, any other nation.
And we do a lot of things.
We actually pack like more
than 10 web applications
into a tiny two-megabyte
package that
doesn't have a whole lot of
dependencies, and most of them
are sort of schlepped
into the package.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Usually the small ones
have a lot of dependencies.
So this is nice.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: I know.
And when I first joined
the TensorBoard team,
we actually had, in terms of our
tooling, over 900 dependencies.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
JUSTINE TUNNEY:
Yeah, and I managed
to pare that down
somewhat, thanks
to the benefits of Bazel.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That would just
take a long time to compile with
all those dependencies, right?
JUSTINE TUNNEY: No, TensorBoard
actually compiles very fast.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, it does?
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Like, you
can compile TensorBoard
and download all
its dependencies
in maybe five to
10 seconds or so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow, OK.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Yeah,
it's not like TensorFlow,
where it takes 30 minutes.
Speaking of which, if you've
got a 96 core Cloud VM,
it takes five.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
it's worth waiting for.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: It is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, say I
want to be a plugin developer,
and I want to start
building my own plugin.
I've come up with a great
idea for great scenario.
How would I get
started doing this?
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Well, the
best way to get started
is we have a repo
call on GitHub called
TensorFlow/TensorBoard
plugin example.
And this is an
independent repository.
It does not vendor
TensorBoard or TensorFlow.
And it basically
shows you how you
can configure Bazel to
do a custom static build
of TensorBoard, where
you can do whatever
you want in a separate repo.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: So this is
basically our escape hatch.
Because with the security and
various other requirements
of TensorBoard, sometimes
merging things upstream cannot
always be approved.
But we provide this alternative.
But we are, of course,
open and welcome
to accepting contributions
on our main GitHub.
And you'll notice inside
our main GitHub repository,
there's a list of
plugins, and each one
has a README with
documentation on how it works.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, perfect, perfect.
So thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of The Developer Show.
Don't forget to check out
the description below,
and we'll put all the links
that we spoke about today.
And thanks so much, Justine.
JUSTINE TUNNEY: Thank
you for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You're welcome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]